[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
mietri Serien guten Abend Katja Stresow
ist mit mir im Studio hat später ein
bisschen Fußball ein bisschen Tennis und
Special Olympics genau schönen guten
Abend und dann schauen wir was wir
ansonsten für Sie vorbereitet haben
ein Rivale und Partner zu Besuch in
Berlin die Bundesregierung lautet aus
wie das Verhältnis zu China künftig
aussehen kann
zu wenig Geld für Arbeit hinter Gittern
das Bundesverfassungsgericht beanstandet
die Entlohnung von Häftlingen
Fahrradfahren zwischen Wunsch und
Wirklichkeit immer mehr Menschen nutzen
das alternative Verkehrsmittel aber der
aus- und Umbau der Wege hängt hinterher
[Musik]
wie halten wir es mit China beim
heutigen regierungsaustausch zwischen
Berlin und Peking galt es diese Frage
mal wieder auszuloten seit dem
ukrainekrieg ist es komplizierter
geworden Kritikpunkte wie Menschenrechte
oder der Umgang mit Oppositionellen
bleiben zwar aktuell aber ohne echte
Konsequenzen zu wichtig gegenseitige
Abhängigkeiten und Handelsbeziehungen
allein im letzten Jahr da gingen Waren
im Wert von knapp
299 Milliarden Euro zwischen beiden
Ländern hin und her Deutschland liefert
vor allem Autos Autoteile und Maschinen
China Notebooks Smartphones aber auch
Rohstoffe und zwar in den letzten Jahren
immer mehr so dass die deutsche
Abhängigkeit von chinesischen waren
deutlich zugenommen hat Heike landski
ein Balanceakt für den Gastgeber der
Kanzler und der chinesische
Ministerpräsident am Tag 3 des
Deutschland Besuchs Empfang mit
militärischen Ehren harmonische Bilder
die Zusammenarbeit statt Konfrontation
symbolisieren sollen
Deutschland will unabhängiger werden
lieferkettenbreiter aufstellen China
sucht die wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit
tritt aggressiver auf und ist einer der
engsten Verbündeten Russlands ich habe
erneut an die chinesische Regierung
appelliert in diesem Krieg noch stärker
ihren Einfluss auf Russland gelten zu
machen
ständiges Mitglied der Fahrten des
UN-Sicherheitsrates trägt China hier
eine ganz besondere Aufgabe ich habe
egal wie die internationale Lage sich
verändert China wird an der
grundlegenden nationalen Politik
Festhalten der Öffnung nach außen und
der Öffnung für eine Strategie zum
gegenseitigen Nutzen
eine scham-offensive Fragen jedoch
wurden dem Gast zuliebe nicht zugelassen
die Opposition bemängelt die fehlende
china-strategie der Ampel ich glaube
dass die chinesische Regierung eine sehr
klaren Plan hat was sie in den nächsten
10 20 Jahren gegenüber dem Westen
erreichen will dass aber dieser Plan
weder bei der Bundesregierung noch in
der Europäischen Union bisher die nötige
klare Antwort gefunden hat zum Schluss
eine Absichtserklärung zur Einrichtung
eines Klima und transformations-
mehr war nicht drin Theo Koll in Berlin
auf der einen Seite will die
Bundesregierung sich wirtschaftlich
abgrenzen gleichzeitig werden
Handelsvolumen und Abhängigkeiten immer
größer wie soll das also funktionieren
ja absolut die Frage führt mitten in den
Kern der Debatte die ja auch innerhalb
der Ampel noch nicht abgeschlossen ist
deshalb gibt's ja auch noch immer keine
offizielle china-strategie das war heute
eine hochinteressante Gradwanderung denn
die Bundesregierung hat ja in ihrer
neuen Sicherheitsstrategie des
Verhältnis zu China zumindest schon mal
mit drei Begriffen beschrieben Partner
Wettbewerbe und systemischer Rivale und
als Rivale und Wettbewerber wird China
immer stärker und immer aggressiver der
Begriff Rivale kam aber heute einfach
nicht vor und das in der Pressekonferenz
keine Fragen zugelassen waren das ist
extrem ungewöhnlich und war nach allem
was ich weiß Folge einer klaren
chinesischen Erpressung entweder so oder
es gibt keine Pressekonferenz und das
zeigt im Kleinen wie schwierig der
Umgang mit diesem mächtigen Land ist von
dem wir ja in in den Bereichen
wirtschaftlich noch viel abhängiger sind
als wir es je von russischer Energie
waren China ist unser wichtigster
Handelspartner und es wird dauern bis
die Abhängigkeiten entscheidend
verringert wurden nicht zu vergessen
wichtige Teile der deutschen Wirtschaft
wollen auch weiter in China Geld
verdienen auch das gehört zur Wahrheit
dazu danke für die Hintergründe nach
Berlin und egal wie sich die Beziehungen
entwickeln laut Bundesamt für
Verfassungsschutz bleibt China aktuell
eine der größten Bedrohungen in Bezug
auf Spionage das geht aus dem heute
veröffentlichten Verfassungsschutz
Bericht 2022 hervor und in dem gibt es
auch viel Interessantes zur Bedrohung im
Inland da hat sich nämlich einiges
verschoben und verändert mehr von Klaus
Brodbeck
es gibt angenehme rektüre selbst im
politischen Berlin fast 400 Seiten die
es in sich haben die Zahl
gewaltorientierter Extremisten steigt
zum Teil werden die Extremisten immer
jünger sie sind weniger ideologisch
festgelegt und basteln ihr Weltbild nach
einem Baukastenprinzip mit
Versatzstücken aus dem Internet zusammen
die Grenzen zwischen ideologisch
festgelegten Lagern verschwimmen rund
38.800 Personen stuft der
Verfassungsschutz als rechtsextrem ein
Plus
14,5% auch weil durch die Einstufung der
AFD als Verdachtsfall nun ein
erheblicher Teil ihrer Parteimitglieder
mitgezählt wird die Zahl
rechtsextremistischer Straftaten stieg
um 4% auf fast 21.000 darunter rund
1.000 Gewalttaten und zwei versuchte
Tötungsdelikte wir dürfen die
mörderische Gefahr durch
Rechtsextremismus
und rechts Terrorismus niemals
unterschätzen die Zahl
linksextremistischer Straftaten sank auf
rund 3.800 - 37% ähnlich der Rückgang
von Gewalttaten aber auch hier ein
versuchtes Tötungsdelikt und kein Grund
zur Entwarnung dennoch zeigen einzelne
besonders erhebliche Angriffe zahlreiche
Körperverletzungen und die regelmäßig
verursachten hohen Schadensummen durch
Brandstiftung oder Sachbeschädigung des
unverändert Ruhe Gefährdungspotenzial
auch die Bedrohungen durch islamistische
Extremisten durch Reichsbürger und
Selbstverwalter durch Spionage etwa
Chinas und Russlands bestimmten
unverändert hinzukommt dass Teile der
Politik russische Propaganda
verbreiteten darunter auch die AFD
wie viele sind wir eigentlich in
Deutschland leben laut Statistischen
Bundesamt so viele Menschen wie nie
zuvor dem nach waren es Ende 2022
84,4 Millionen etwa 1,1 Millionen mehr
als ein Jahr zuvor der Grund ein
deutlicher Anstieg der Zuwanderung vor
allem durch Kriegsflüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine
für die Ukraine hat die EU-Kommission in
den nächsten vier Jahren 50 Milliarden
Euro in Aussicht gestellt was die
Kampfhandlungen im Land angeht wieder
hat es in den verschiedenen Regionen
massive Angriffe gegeben im Osten läuft
weiterhin die Gegenoffensive des
ukrainischen Militärs wie hart umkämpft
die Gefechte rund um bachmut sind zeigt
jetzt der Bericht von Tobias Häfner
es ist im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes ein
Kampf um jeden Meter rund um die völlig
zerstörte Stadt bachmut
Nadelstiche setzen aus dem Schutz von
Schützengräben kleine Gebiete von den
Russen zurückerobern das ist derzeit das
Ziel der ukrainischen Armee
ein Reporter-Team des britischen Senders
BBC hat eine Brigade der Ukraine weiter
südlich bei Don jetzt bis an die
vorderste Front begleitet Bilder die den
Schrecken des kriegsalltags zeigen
zurückgelassen Ausrüstung der Russen vom
Westen gelieferte zerstörte ukrainische
Fahrzeuge aber vor allem immer wieder
tote Leichen um die sich auf dem
Schlachtfeld zur Zeit niemand kümmert
ständig sind Schüsse zu hören
[Applaus]
gibt es häufig
gehen sie in den Bunker sagt ein Soldat
als Geschosse in der Nähe der
Journalisten einschlagen
der größte Vorteil der Russen ist dass
sie für den Angriff Luftstreitkräfte
haben Helikopter und Kampfflugzeuge
und diesen Vorteil zeigt Moskau
weiterhin mit Hochglanz Bildern vor wohl
vor allem als Signal der Stärke für die
Russen vor den Fernsehschirmen nicht nur
der Kampf um die Ukraine sondern auch um
die Köpfe der Weltöffentlichkeit geht
weiter
ein wichtiger Handelspartner für
Deutschland in Zentralasien ist das
autoritär regierte Kasachstan jetzt
wollen beide Länder noch enger
zusammenrücken darauf einigten sich die
Präsidenten Steinmeier und türkeif beim
Treffen in Astana gab es auch ein
konkretes Ergebnis Kasachstan wird bis
Ende kommenden Jahres jeden Monat
100.000 Tonnen Rohöl liefern und zwar an
die Raffinerie PCK im brandenburgischen
Schwedt dort wurde bis Ende letzten
Jahres vor allem Öl aus Russland
verarbeitet
jetzt nach Deutschland und zu einem
höchst umstrittenen Stundenlohn ein Euro
37 so viel verdienen manche Häftlinge
die im Gefängnis Arbeiten zu wenig und
verfassungswidrig das hat heute das
oberste deutsche Gericht entschieden
zumindest für Bayern und
Nordrhein-Westfalen der Lohn müsse so
hoch sein dass er zur Resozialisierung
der Gefangenen beitrageargumentieren die
Richter in Karlsruhe Birgit Franke
berichtet
will montieren für knapp 15 Euro am Tag
so viel verdienen die Inhaftierten
durchschnittlich in der JVA Frankenthal
die Arbeit bringt zwar Struktur in den
Alltag doch von dem Verdienst bleibt
nichts übrig es reicht gerade für z.B
Getränke und Hygieneartikel so ein
Häftling der anonym bleiben will
Pfändung hat oder Gerichtskosten wird
das alles weggenommen und somit kann man
am Ende des Monats auch nichts sparen
das Bundesverfassungsgericht stärkt
heute die Rechte der Gefangenen die Höhe
der Vergütung ist in einzelnen
Bundesländern verfassungswidrig die
Gefangenen müssen sehen dass sich die
Arbeit lohnt dabei darf auch die
Wahrnehmung der Vergütung durch die
Gefangenen selbst nicht unberücksichtigt
bleiben weil sich das Empfinden in ihrer
Tätigkeit nicht genügend wertgeschätzt
zu werden auf deren Resozialisierung
kontraproduktiv auswirken kann
die Beklagten Länder Bayern und NRW
müssen jetzt neue Konzepte zur
Resozialisierung erarbeiten die Kosten
die ein Gefangener pro Tag verursacht
müssen dabei auch berücksichtigt werden
die Richterin und Richter am
Bundesverfassungsgericht haben
klargemacht dass die Länder zwar
grundsätzlich frei sind wie sie ihr
resozialisierungskonzept gestalten ob
sich gefangen zum Beispiel an den
Haftkosten beteiligen müssen die
Vergütung muss allerdings realistisch
sein für geleistete Arbeit muss es eine
angemessene Anerkennung geben
ein Appell an alle Landesgesetzgeber ihr
vergütungskonzept zu überprüfen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat ihnen bis
Mitte 2025 Zeit eingeräumt
wie kann Fahrradfahren sicherer gemacht
werden darüber diskutieren seit heute
Experten auf dem nationalen
radverkehrskongress das ist auch
deswegen so wichtig weil immer mehr aufs
Fahrrad umsteigen
der Umsatz der Fahrradbranche der
verdreifachte sich innerhalb von zehn
Jahren auf mehr als 7 Milliarden Euro im
vergangenen Jahr wurden insgesamt 4,6
Millionen Fahrräder verkauft 2,2
Millionen davon waren E-Bikes also fast
die Hälfte in diesem Jahr könnten die
E-Bikes erstmals die Nase vorn haben
Peters
Aufbau der Eurobike der größten radmesse
der Welt in Frankfurt die Branche boomt
die Lieferketten Probleme aus der
corona-zeit gehören der Vergangenheit an
vor allem E-Bikes sind Verkaufsschlager
machen mittlerweile um die 50% der
Verkäufer aus für die Zukunft gehen wir
ganz fest davon aus dass das Fahrrad
wirklich auf der Überholspur ist immer
mehr Menschen kaufen sich E-Bikes immer
mehr Menschen nutzen des Fahrrad in der
Stadt und das Fahrrad wird ganz bestimmt
der Gewinner der Verkehrswende
allerdings die Voraussetzungen dass die
Fahrräder eine größere Rolle im
Straßenverkehr spielen lassen oft zu
wünschen übrig Beispiel Frankfurt
Friedberger Landstraße eine wichtige
Verkehrsachse doch der Radweg endet
plötzlich im Nichts und das Einrichten
einer Tempo 30 Zone und wenigstens für
etwas mehr Sicherheit zu sorgen dass
scheiter bisher am deutschen
Straßenverkehrsrecht weil das bestehende
Straßenverkehrsgesetz und die
nachgeordnete
Straßenverkehrsordnung dort im Grunde
genommen sagt
also hier müssen drei Leute zu Tode
kommen bevor wir hier Tempo 30 anordnen
können und das ist einfach weltfremd was
wir in Frankfurt viel als Feedback
bekommen auch durch den fahrradklima
Test ist dass die Leute die Radweg
Lücken besonders bemängeln das heißt sie
wissen nicht dass sie auf der gesamten
Strecke ein sicheren Radweg vorfinden
werden es gibt immer wieder das Stück
gelungen zwischen Radweg und kein Radweg
immerhin ein neuer Entwurf für das
Straßenverkehrsgesetz liegt jetzt vor es
soll wohl den Vorrang des Autos
einschränken und den Kommunen mehr
eigene Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten
einräumen morgen soll der Entwurf ins
Bundeskabinett kommen
zwei Entscheidungen zum Thema
Umweltschutz zum einen wollen die
EU-Länder stark beanspruchtete Flächen
wieder herstellen auf eine entsprechende
Vorordnung haben sie sich heute geeinigt
bis zum Jahr 20 30 sollen mindestens 20%
der Flächen renaturiert werden geplant
ist auch eine wiederbewässerung von
Mooren und Flussauen deutsche Landwirte
befürchten dadurch Einnahme Ausfälle
jetzt zum anderen die UNO hat sich nach
jahrelang Verhandlungen auf ein Abkommen
zum Schutz der Meere geeinigt
Generalsekretär
uterisch sagte es gebe neue Hoffnung den
mehren eine Überlebenschance zu geben
Greenpeace sprach von einem Sieg für
alles Leben auf dem Planeten die
Vereinbarung schafft die Möglichkeit
große Schutzgebiete auch in der Hochsee
auszuweisen außerdem sollen Aktivitäten
künftig auf Umweltverträglichkeit
geprüft werden die einzelnen Staaten
müssen das Abkommen noch ratifizieren
es sollte eine Tauchfahrt zum legendären
Wrack der Titanic sein jetzt könnte das
Abenteuer für die fünf Passagiere zur
Tragödie werden denn der Kontakt
zwischen ihrem Mini-U-Boot und der
Außenwelt ist Sonntagmorgen abgerissen
die Zeit rennt jetzt der Sauerstoff
reicht laut Betreiber für vier Tage das
Tauchboot wird bei Neufundland vermisst
unweit der Stelle an der die Titanic vor
111 Jahren gesunken war Johannes Hano
knapp sieben Meter lang und zehn Tonnen
schwer vermisst im Nordatlantik zwischen
Kanada und den USA es ist die Suche nach
der Nadel im Heuhaufen am Sonntag war
das Tauchboot der Firma Ocean Gate
expeditions mit fünf Menschen an Bord
auf dem Weg zum Wrack der Titanic
darunter ein Wissenschaftler und drei
Touristen aus Großbritannien und
Pakistan die 250.000 Dollar für den
Tauchgang bezahlt haben nach einer
Stunde und 45 Minuten bricht der Kontakt
zum Begleitschiff ab die Rettungsmission
schwierig
das Suchgebiet liegt etwa 1500 km
östlich von Cape Cott in einer
Wassertiefe von knapp 4000 m
es ist eine sehr weit abgelegene Gegend
und es ist eine große Herausforderung
dort eine Suche durchzuführen
für 96 Stunden hat das Tauchboot
Sauerstoff von Bord und so bleibt den
Retter nicht viel Zeit das Boot
aufzuspüren und im Notfall auch zu heben
es ist ein Rennen gegen die Zeit
unsere Einsatzkräfte haben die Fähigkeit
visuelle als auch Radar suchen
durchzuführen und die Kanadier können so
hier abwerfen
bisher aber ist völlig unklar wo sich
das Tauchboot befindet ob in 3800 Metern
tiefer auf dem Meeresgrund oder du bist
irgendwo an der Oberfläche treibt das
wäre das beste Szenario denn der
Sauerstoff an Bord geht so Nike
ja und mehr zum verschollenen U-Boot
gibt es ab 19 Uhr 30 auch bei ZDF heute
live auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
und in der ZDF heute App so jetzt geht
es hier bei uns sportlich weiter
alexander sverev ist gestartet und zwar
sehr gut ins ATP Turnier in Halle
Westfalen in seinem Auftakt Match hatte
es Alexander Zverev mit dem Österreicher
Dominic Thiem zu tun den er durchaus als
seinen Freund bezeichnet Gastgeschenke
hat das wäre auf heute aber nicht dabei
er gewann 6:36:4
mit Alexander Zverev beim Aufschlag ist
heute nicht zu spaßen Dominic Thiem aus
Österreich kommt nicht hinterher auf der
anderen Seite nach etwas mehr als einer
halben Stunde ist der erste Satz
erledigt 63 für den Olympiasieger
im zweiten Satz wird Team etwas besser
aber nicht entscheiden der Macht zu
viele Fehler es verwandelt den ersten
von drei Matchbällen zum Sex zu drei und
sechs zu vier Sieg morgen spielte in der
nächsten Runde gegen den Kanadier Dennis
[Applaus]
nach Berlin zu den Welt spielen der
Menschen mit geistiger Beeinträchtigung
heute Dritter Wettkampftag wieder mit
Medaillen für Deutschland wieder mit
bester Stimmung
Zuschauer haben ein Herz für die Spiele
und Bewunderung für alle die daran
teilnehmen sichtbare Lebensfreude
Strahlen Athleten und Athletinnen aus
auf der ganz großen Bühne und sie zeigen
worum es auch geht um Anerkennung es
geht darum sein Bestes zu geben und
dabei Spaß zu haben und Medaillen sind
durchaus willkommen perfekt läuft es
heute für die deutsche Elvira amirov
Gold über 50 m Brust und auch
teamkolleges die Schröder kann eine
Bronze-Medaille erkämpfen die Special
Olympics sind ein Fest und die
Begeisterung ist nicht nur in Berlin
ansteckend
am Abend spielt die DFB-Elf der Männer
in Gelsenkirchen vor das letzte
Testspiel vor der Sommerpause es geht
gegen Kolumbien alle hoffen endlich auf
einen Sieg und auf die erfolgsauer von
Ilkay geboren
beim DFB lange unterschätzt als Kapitän
von Manchester City unangefochtener
Führungsspieler Champions League Sieger
englischer Meister und Pokalsieger
Ilkay Gündogan soll jetzt das fehlende
Puzzleteil im Nationalteam sein der den
haben sie fliegt dringend braucht ein
Spieler der hohe Qualität hat aber das
auch er auch ein sehr intelligenter
Spieler pep Guardiola hat den Wert des
32-Jährigen erkannt im Nationalteam
bislang nie gesetzt will Gündogan mit
dem Rückenwind des Triple Siegers nun
endlich auch eine feste Größe
Unterhaching werden
feste Größe ist dein Stichwort
danke Katja also kein großes
Fußballturnier ohne Maskottchen also so
viel PR muss sein das finden zumindest
die Macher der Fußball-EM 2024 in
Deutschland schauen Sie mal es ist ein
Teddybär mit einem dicken Kopf kurzen
Armen und Beinen Namen hat er zwar noch
nicht aber immerhin hat der Bär mehr als
das WM Maskottchen von 2006 Goleo der
Löwe hatte nämlich keine Hose zumindest
dieser Sport wird dem Fußballverband
also erspart bleiben
so beim Wetter da gibt es gehöriges
unwetterpotenzial mehr dazu gleich von
Österreich ab 21:45 Uhr der
Verfassungsschutzpräsident halten wann
im heute journal Interview mit Christian
Sievers schönen Dank fürs Interesse und
ihnen noch einen entspannten Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend und herzlich willkommen zum
Wetter aus dem Süden erreichte uns
weiterhin sehr warme Luft und warme Luft
kann sehr viel Feuchtigkeit aufnehmen
und das spüren wir mit heftigen Schauern
und Gewittern die ziehen dann morgen im
Tagesverlauf allmählich nordostwärts
aber kühlere Luft erreicht uns auch und
sorgt dann spätestens am Freitag für
Wetterberuhigung in der Nacht gibt es
teils kräftige Gewitter ziehen
allmählich nord-ostwärts und in der
ersten Nachthälfte sind im Südwesten
teilweise Unwetter dabei einzelne
Gewitter können größeren Hagel
produzieren teilweise sogar Orkanböen
und stark kriegen das ganze schwächt
sich während der Bewegung nach Nordosten
allmählich ab Temperaturen 21 Grad ganz
im Westen Deutschlands und 15 Grad an
den Alpen und morgen dann wieder Schauer
und Gewitter teilweise im
unwetterbereich mit Hagel ganz im Norden
bleibt es größtenteils trocken höchste
Temperatur und 32 Grad in Bayern und 24
Grad an der Nordsee und am Donnerstag
erreichte uns ein ganzes Unwetter tief
und legt bei den Unwetter noch mal eine
Schippe oben drauf bis 34 Grad und damit
ein schöner Abend